obliterate a [__] lot of Y scumbags
kill all of Y scum then wipe them off
the map WIP
off do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad Arad Muhammad Arad has helped
develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this
course to access the free lifechanging
training
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in I came
to see our beloved brother Z how you
doing aldah is I want to say quite new
into the D but alhamdulillah you can
follow him on Instagram what's your name
on Instagram uh Zade s z a i d SB a i d
it'll be in the description below in
we're going to put it there say you can
follow him for daily reminders in he's
also on tuck Tik Tok and maybe one day
on YouTube so in I do have a YouTube but
I just don't have time to to post it but
all all the videos and shorts are on
there in okay no problem so we're going
to get straight into this video there
are two videos we're going to be
reacting to where there are these
huligan thugs um obviously were invited
by the cad we know who he is Tommy
Robinson yeah and funnily enough when
the police arrested them they actually
found classy drugs on them um which is
you know either cocaine really or heroin
yeah so they a bunch of crackers in a
nutshell in as you can see because the
one who's inviting them use donation
monies that he raised for his cabit what
do you expect from his followers yeah
same thing so here's the videos we're
going to react to brother sisters where
you can see these individuals who are
accusing the pro Palestinian protesters
of being terrorist sympathizers and
let's see who is the real terrorist in
this equation let's watch for ourself
initate a [__] lot of Y scumbags kill
all of Y scum
[Music]
radic
[__]
the
Terror
[__] you have no [__] clue know
what [__] day it is today you know
why
[__] yeah
have you got the video and we really
need to report him if I was there his
back bag would have been carrying him
home um you know backpack he carries his
backpack would have been carrying him
home he's brave enough he basically
speaking like that to a bunch of sisters
by the way oh is it the sisters bro I
thought he was speaking to that man no
no no he's not bro he came after having
a got that man but the on who's holding
the camera are a bunch of females and
these cowards are known for that on the
streets the only thing that they do is
attack Muslim woman
most them are cowards in a bunch they
start acting Brave even then if you give
a couple of them a few slaps the ones in
the backr away is well you know Allah
says in the Quran anyways but that's a
different verse I don't want to get into
um but you know don't worry get trouble
what you what you what you make out like
when you see people like this because
there's another video where they were
basically having to go out Pro pales
protesters and there's one thing this
guy said he was like wipe them off the
map we're going to kill a lot of you
yeah okay I mean what does that remind
you when when you hear them saying that
isn't that exactly what is going on in
occupied Palestine exactly that's exact
and if you think about it this is
Terrorism this is Terrorism so if bro
it's so ironic there's men women and
children being massacred in Palestine
and this guy has the audacity to come
and say you are terrorist while he is
perpetrating and propagating and not
only that propagating acts of terrorism
by say we're going to wipe you all out
you don't think he's drunk wipe him off
the map he's definitely not drunk bro
like you get it and and there's no
excuse even if you're drunk should be
honest if you're drunk then you are
actually when you're drunk comes out
exactly I don't know cuz I've never
drunk I've never been drunk but I've
seen people who are drunk and yes you
see the the true side come out so show
is there any specific ay in the Quran or
verse that you know of you know maybe
you can share with the the viewers yes
Allah says in
[Music]
the the Jews and the Christians
non-believers anyone against Islam
anyone who's not a Muslim will never
accept you ever until you follow their
culture their Creed until you follow
them exactly the way they dress the way
they drink the way they entertain
themselves until you love football like
them until you go to the pubs like them
until you smoke like them that is the
only time that they will actually you
know accept you if not you if you don't
do that there will always be enemies
against you so this teaches is a very
important lesson don't try and suck up
to these kinds of people and try and
like sympathize with them and make them
love you no they're never going to like
you even if they portray on the face
image that they like you and that you're
beloved to them no deep down they don't
like you cuz Allah says this in the
Quran these are the words of Allah not
my words exactly in an our show guys and
this is why we need to understand that
our inferiority complex this is what the
Muslims are suffering from this weakness
infer complex listen be sure of yourself
when I came to Islam 10 years ago Islam
was the last religion I would have
picked was 9/11 what is crazy Stu
happening my family hated Islam but to
me I had to look in the mirror and be
like am I going to lie to myself for the
rest of my life knowing that this is the
truth and I said to myself no I'm going
to accept this Faith even if the
comes against me why because it is the
truth and not only that their propaganda
and their hate is actually working
against them because there are there was
a fous Tik toer a a female who actually
accepted Islam she's a black sister she
accepted Islam recently and many of them
like that look into the Quran and Islam
why cuz we are amazed of the
Palestinians Faith I've been reading the
Quran and I have a lot to say especially
because I grew up as an Evangelical
Christian now did I expect for me to
read the Quran and it resonate with my
the core beliefs and values I already
have but I don't think I've ever
understood anything as much as I've
understood the Quran I'm no longer a
Christian reading Quran I am now a
Muslim reading Quran alhamdulillah I am
Muslim today bro there are people who
are in the west sitting down and
watching what's happening in pisan and
saying oh my IM is shaken in Allah and
then it's funnily enough the people who
are getting bombed and blown into pieces
are saying the IM is increasing but
you're say in the w conf s for eating
peanuts and your IM is being affected I
have something beautiful to share about
that please in the story of M this is
something many of you will have never
heard before it's a very interesting
story we know that the sorcerers they
came did they not and it was a it was it
was a day where it was like a festival
so everyone came the whole media was
there everything in the Quran is related
today's day and age there is a today
there is a ham today there is
a today it is exactly the same the
sorcerers are the magician The Magicians
are the medium they what do on people's
eyes they make huh illusion illusion
they make you think that the truth is
falser than the false of is truth they
trick you this is exactly what the media
do especially the BBC and what are the
other ones CNN Fox News you know they
brainwash you into making they trick
your eyes into making you believe that
what you see is what basically what they
want Subhan Allah when the sorcerers
came on this day that that M called them
to is mentioned in
and threw down his staff and it turned
into a snake and it ate all the other
sticks of the sorcerers I'm not going to
get into the story you can just go watch
the story of M if you don't know what
I'm on about what did the sorcerers do
when they saw this clear sign
this they prostrated the sorcerers the
media what they were like no this is a
clear truth the reason the reason being
they submitted is because they knew what
their illusion is and how they do it so
they were aware of
what what they're doing is not real so
when they saw what a real Miracle is yes
that yeah and why is this relatable to
what's going on right now in Palestine
because if you look at the media if you
look on Tik Tok and Instagram and all
these kinds of things you will have
people from the West not Muslims who are
now sympathizing with the truth who are
now sympath sympathizing with Palestine
the Clear Proof of that this regime is a
genocidal regime is mass slaughtering
people and bombing them in hospitals you
can't hide it anymore you can't hide it
any more so the sorcerers the media some
of them some of them okay they're now on
the side of Palestine and sorry to to
finish off no pleas what's fascinating
is I I bet you which is what did he said
to the
sorcerers the point is that the I.E
let's just say Netanyahu because he is a
yeah he mod Pharaoh he is going to say
to those who go against his his
propaganda how are you disobeying my
propaganda how are you now believing
them when I didn't give you permission
to do so and now he's going to punish
them watch this is going to happen
exactly and that's what's happening and
so much so they try to do fake news and
fake propaganda and so much so now some
of well most most of them are admitting
that saying yes we we want GAA wiped out
I mean at least you can admire their
honesty which is shown to the whole
world and this is going to go down
history brother and sisters and the
whole world is sadly you know why
they're shooting theirself on the foot
the whole world is seeing how evil and
Cru they are and they are they are
losing this war they are losing it that
is it from me and brother Zade inah you
can follow him on Instagram and Tik Tok
I'll put the links in the description
box below may Allah bless you guys if
you want to see more reaction videos of
myself and brother Z please comment
section below and send us videos you
would like like us to react to till next
time